j'ai été abandonné à l'aéroport d'orly
c'était le 17 septembre 1994
jeune femme de travailler à un desk de
location de voitures a trouvé une
poussette et dans la poussette il y
avait une petite fille
qui gazouille et cette petite fille
c'était moi
[Musique]
pour brut
on a rencontré emilie un bébé abandonné
dans un aéroport
il y à 26 ans aujourd'hui adultes emilie
ne connais ni sa date de naissance ni
son lieu de naissance ni même son prénom
de naissance une quête d'identité
qu'elle a accepté de nous raconter
quand on me demande d'où je viens je
sais que j'ai un d'ardèche
c'est ma terre natale on est à empuré ni
en ardèche
mes parents adoptifs sont originaires de
ce village et donc j'ai grandi toute mon
enfance d'où je viens c'est la question
je pense qu'on m'a le plus posé moi je
répondais toujours juin d'ardèche et les
gens me disaient non mais enfin je veux
dire hein ça se voit que tu as les
origines d'ailleurs en grandissant j'ai
vraiment senti ce côté mystérieux autour
autour de mon abandon c'est pas anodin
de laisser un enfant comme ça
[Musique]
j'ai été trouvé dans une poussette grise
elle était en plus tôt bon état un sac à
langer avec à l'intérieur des vêtements
la tenue dans laquelle j'ai été trouvé
une couverture et l'optique la police de
l'air est intervenue
ils ont épluché les les vols en arrivées
et au départ d'orly ce jour là ça n'a
rien donné et du coup comme il savait
pas trop quoi faire de plus que ça j'ai
été prise en charge et j'ai été emmenée
en pouponnière la directrice m'a donné
un prénom à prioriser le prénom le 19
septembre c'est la saint émile et donc
mon prénom a été décidé comme ça donc
c'est vraiment une identité est fabriqué
je suis resté six mois jusqu'à ce que je
sois adoptée par mes parents il
s'appelle donc monique et philippe donc
ils sont tous les deux ardéchois avec ma
mère tout de suite je suis allé vers
elle tout de suite ça a été très
fusionnelle entre nous ça c'est notre
première rencontre
c'était la première fois je vais toucher
la main et en fait elle est venue dans
les bras et là elle est restée pendant
au moins une demi-heure sans bouger
contre moi quoi
cette rencontre elle était voilà c'était
une logique quand j'avais 27 ans l'avait
vraiment cette cette douleur très
profonde et cette détresse de me dire
elle est où ma maman pourquoi elle mal
et c'est pourquoi mon papa il m'a laissé
sagement rappelle le soir on allait
faire la lecture et le bisou elles nous
disent maintenant j'aurai bien voir ma
mère alors moi je faisais bonjour maman
est là et tout mais elle me dit non mais
pas toi je me voir l'autre ça lui
revenait en plein fouet quoi j'ai aucune
information sur le bébé que c'était
avant d'être trouvée et c'est ça en fait
qu'ils aient obsédant c'est qu'il ya
tellement possibilité que je me dis
c'est laquelle la possibilité parce que
je comprends pas
[Musique]
25 juillet 2017 avec mes parents on a
ouvert mon dossier d'adoption qui était
dans les bureaux de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance donc anciennement la dass
dedans il y avait le procès verbal qui a
été établi à la suite de mon abandon
[Musique]
on ouvre les premières pages et vraiment
je prends conscience à ce moment là que
y aura rien de plus et je me dis ok bon
ben ça fait 23 ans personne n'a cherché
quand elle a ouvert son dossier on a
tous tous les trois on a pleuré parce
qu'en fait on s'est rendu compte de tout
ce qu'elle avait dû vivre pendant cette
période en fait où elle a été laissée
cette thériault là c'était vraiment une
une période qu'il avait mal qu'il avait
marqué très profondément
[Musique]
quand on a ouvert mon dossier après avec
mes parents on en a discuté et je leur
disais mais cette poussette du coup
enfin
on a fait quoi et en fait c'est là
qu'ils m'ont dit en fait elle est dans
le grenier
l'été 2010 est avec ma mère on l'a sorti
un jour et on l'a retourné dans tous les
sens pour essayer de le voir si c'est
pas un petit mot enfin quelque chose un
indice quelque chose qui pouvait nous
donner des informations ou une marque
quelque chose comme ça et il y en n'a
rien trouvé c'est le néant
enfin quand tu lis la définition de ce
que c'est le néant
je dis ouais c'est un océan de vie de
quoi le truc c est ça te fous tu as ça
te prend là et tu te dis mais ses
angoisses menteuse dire rien quoi ça
fait 26 ans que les questions des
milliers restent sans réponse en avril
2020 alors que la france est confiné
emilie lance un appel sur les réseaux
sociaux une bouteille à la mer pour
retrouver ses parents biologiques
je regardais un film est en fait il y
avait une dame qui disaient quelque part
il ya quelqu'un qui sait quelque chose
cette phrase a été le déclic je me suis
dit pour moi aussi quelque part ya
quelqu'un qui sait quelque chose il faut
que je trouve cette personne je surfais
beaucoup sur internet je voyais qu'il y
avait plein plein plein de gens
connectés tout le temps je me suis dit
ben je vais je vais essayer de faire
avancer mon histoire
s'il vous plaît aidez moi à partager ce
message et ses photos sur les réseaux
partout et à tout le monde
je suis sûr que quelque part quelqu'un
sait quelque chose
donc je partage vers 20 heures le soir
et en fait à minuit je croyais avait
déjà dit mille par terre
au bout de deux trois jours on est à 30
40 mille partage et au bout d'une
semaine je crois qu'on avait atteint les
130 ou 140 milles partage au départ je
reçois beaucoup de messages surtout de
la réunion et de l'île maurice
après aussi madagascar après plus assez
tendue coup plus un voyage loin là les
gens m'écrivent en me disant c'est sûr
tu me ressens tu ressembles à ma mère
qui ressemble à ma soeur je ressemble à
ma cousine
[Musique]
dans tous les messages que j'ai reçus il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui me
disaient en fait avec ton histoire au
point où en est le moyen le plus
efficace pour pouvoir obtenir des
informations c'est faire un test adn
j'ouvre donc les résultats et là je me
rends compte que du coup je suis métisse
que
j'ai 50 % de mes origines kenyanes de
l'inde que je suis 15% à peu près
türk il ya 35 % européenne et du coup je
suis 9 % française
moi je me sens totalement française
j'étais super contente de voir que
j'avais vraiment d origine française
dans mon adn parce qu'être français il
ya des gens qui pensent qu'il faut être
blanc alors que je pense que la france
l'est et métissée quoi on va dire moi
j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais faire
pour que je sois visible et que les
personnes qui m'ont laissé sied elles
veulent se manifester un jour elle
puisse me trouver sa voie roches lui et
savoir que je m'interroge
moi j'ai fait ma part du chemin
[Musique]
où